oh man kids the heats keep on
coming from ufc last weekend of the big
pay-per-view this weekend ufc 253
is here there's no better place to get
in on all the action with draftking
sportsbook america's top rated
sportsbook app if you haven't tried
draftking sportsbook
head to the app store right now because
you don't want to miss this draftking
sportsbook is giving
all new users the chance to turn one
dollar into 100
that's right you can place a one dollar
bet on either the headline fighter
uh izzy or costo and if the fighter wins
you cash a cool 100
off your dollar how can you guys pass
this up if you're new to draftking
sportsbook
head to the app right now to scout their
latest offers draftkings is safe
reliable secure making it easy for you
to deposit and withdraw your money
at your convenience download the top
rated draftking sportsbook app now use
the promo code fighter
when you sign in to get this you can't
miss offer pick either headline fighter
costo or style bender
during ufc 253 bet one dollar and can
win 100
if they win that's one dollar to win 100
using the promo code
fighter during the sign up for limited
time only at draftking sportsbook
must be 21 or older new jersey indiana
or pennsylvania only
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call when heart
gambler or in indiana one eight hundred
nine with it we live chin well not live
chappelle what's up dog what's going on
you the co-host today man i know this
if that sounds weird that's cool
it's been a long time overdue i mean
usually people see on king of the sting
yeah but you have you've never been on
fire kid all this time no never been on
fire the kid mother and i've known y'all
for
quite some time now so well because
you're a regular but you're a part of
king distinct yeah so i get it yeah you
know what i'm saying
yeah and then our boy malek was supposed
to be here but
uh supposedly got a flat tire on my ass
i'm flat tired my ass can i say ass on
you oh yeah okay you can fire away dude
fire away he uh malik's gonna hang out
with brian count a little too much
because if i had a dime for every time
callan got a
flat tire in our seven year career of
doing podcasting
i'd be a rich man oh he got flat tires a
lot oh dude collins lies
for the longest time they're i'm like
dude you're too old to be lying like
yeah like
just tell me you're late yeah his
excuses were so bad
and when i first met him i was like oh
dang that's crazy man
then about after four weeks i'm like
he's been late every day and there's a
new
he's creative i'll give him that but
after seven years he just ran out of
[ __ ]
like he we'd be taking the same road pch
to get to the studio yeah you're like
dude you never believe it's a water main
broke dude and there's water
all over and i'm stuck i'm like what
wrote you on he's like pch i'm like
i took that right like weird you must
have just missed it
so like oh strange let me bring up my
map and see if it's uh
say it's a traffic delay i bring up maps
nothing nothing
like it's weird they don't show it on
there you know those people just get
exhausted
exhausted aren't you exactly can you
just be
on time tell them the truth is just less
exhausting
dude this this is this this was the
the tipping point for me so brian and i
were at fox sports forever right
and they we pitched them on tv show we
in
the fox sports like digital and sports
side confirmed it they're like yeah we
love it
you gotta pitch it to the head of fox
okay like friday morning
nine a.m and i knew nine am for me ain't
[ __ ]
for brian like oh that's early so i was
like is
nightmare for him so i'm like is there
any way you can do like 10 or 11. like
no [ __ ] the only slot 9 am friday
morning
the head of fox yeah do not be late i'm
like no problem
i the night before i i literally get on
my hands and knees i go brian
dude i don't i don't ask for much i beg
you
do not be late tomorrow voice the minute
on bending now i'm like
i'm like please i'm playing c in the
background like dude please
do not kiss from a rose i'm like do not
be late tomorrow
he goes dude never sure enough i'm there
at 8 50.
no sign for brian i'm going through my
head i'm like parking valid
oh yeah yeah oh my god it's gonna be
close so i'm sitting there with the head
of fox in the office he's like is your
partner coming i'm like
he should be 905. nothing
don't hear anything from brian the guy
goes he's coming i go oh
no i didn't tell you no no so i'm the
one who deals with the business
transaction so i'm gonna be here
and then you know i told him if you want
to you could stop by but really because
i was just trying to come for brian i go
but really it's just our thing because
i'm the one who deals with he goes oh
why don't you say something earlier i'm
like i was waiting on you
and you could tell he's like
[Laughter]
we give him the pitch it goes great
whatever brian comes 30 minutes late
no why did he even show up at that point
why do you even show up
30 minutes late i was so mad see i was
30 minutes early
early's on time dog yeah in sports well
i may think that
was cheerleading strict like for those
of you that don't know chappelle
comes on the road with me he's my future
on the road he's on king of sting we've
been friends for a long time
yeah he's a beast of a comic he was also
a former
cheerleader for a long time competitive
loop chaired at louisville
chilled with his boy uh chaired with his
boy jerry from netflix series
[Laughter]
why you do that what happened
no that guy has a lot of heating
cheering [ __ ] i just want i just want
you know what 2013
was the last time i cheered sure and i
haven't seen brian in two months but
there's still
he on both of us there's still a heat
i don't know him you don't no i don't
know him
i don't know
super competitive cheerleader yeah i was
into it man i really loved it
you were dedicated to it very dedicated
it was i mean it was a
just a great outlet and i was just i
loved like doing the
the flips and [ __ ] it's all about it
badass especially
well because when i was younger i was
into like those martial art films
like and like ninjas doing all the flips
and [ __ ] yeah really martial arts but
yeah sure
yeah okay i feel you okay this is a
jackass no i'm just saying
listen we're talking about five-year-old
chappelle here okay yeah
uh i was ripped but uh i used to watch
those films i see them do the flips
and so i just went outside and was like
i could do that [ __ ] too and just and
just start doing it just started doing
it
and flipping off like table benches all
that stuff man
yeah the misconception is and i mean
rightfully so that most
male cheerleaders are gay yeah that's a
misconception yeah it's the first thing
you say yeah
i think it's fair yeah it's just that's
part of the i'd say the majority are
right
like you were the minority as far as
being the male
in cheerleading yeah i was definitely a
minority but i mean like
all around i know right but it's like if
you're a male hairdresser like just the
assumption is they're
gay yeah which i know tons of male hair
dressers that aren't
i watch project runway and there's a
straight dudes on there that uh
make you know project realm yeah yeah
yeah yeah big fashion yeah
yeah you're looking at anyone yeah but
like even yeah no these ones
these [ __ ] make it oh dig it i
did they make it
like sewing and [ __ ] yeah i mean tommy
hilfiger is not gay
i don't know anything about tommy
hilfiger he's not but dude i'm just
saying like that's
the misconception in any he still makes
clothes oh yeah
for real his son will wrap your [ __ ]
air off too boy he can rap oh yeah
drive bars no he can't he's such a lie
tommy hilfiger
bring him up i mean there's some raps
rap raps
like tom hanks on raps you didn't know
chet hanks either did you no
i don't also white rapper when you're
dead
dude when your dad's force gump it's a
tough [ __ ] going yeah what yeah what
are you yeah you got to do something you
have to do something he'll face some rap
i mean he
literally has like saw his videos on
ricky hill
ricky hill does he have a drug addiction
yes i know i'm like i'm looking at him
i'm like he looks again when your dad's
tommy hill figure
it's a tough that's not a healthy
looking pail you know because there's
regular pail
but
yeah yeah i've watched this one before
ricky ricky hills
rocky hill for whatever reason like he's
got he's got a catchy name
ricky hill yeah yeah ricky hill hey
y'all going to that ricky hill concert
it sounds pretty dope right it does
sound whoa and he's also dating rita ora
he's dating rita ora for a hot second
who's rita ora oh
ooh a diamond i'm so out of touch with
a little diamy diamond from australia
the holiday season is coming up fam and
this year we know
that people will be buying stuff online
more than ever
so if you're selling stuff online you
need to be ready to meet the demand
be ready with shipstation when you're
selling online get a massive amount of
orders out quickly can be
tough how do you keep track with who
gets what what shipping cares should you
use
listen the best rates we got you covered
the choiceshipstation.com it's the
fastest
easiest most affordable way to manage
and ship your orders right just a few
clicks
you know all right from your freaking
phone chip station helps online sellers
get orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website
shipstation brings all your orders into
one simple interface all right ship
station works with all the major
carriers including usps fedex ups
even international no wonder shipstation
is the number one choice of online
sellers
and right now the firing kid listeners
you can try ship station
free for 60 days when you use the code
fighter
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of the massive
online shopping season get started at
shipstation.com
today click on the microphone top of the
homepage type in fighter that's
shipstation.com
enter the offer code fighter
shipstation.com make ship
happen all right kids you ready to cut
your cable cord you're sick of cable
we are too that's why we're switching to
fubo tv for live sports
news and prime time tv without the
complicated contracts
do you love watching tv but hate your
cable company cool
it's time to switch pay less money for
more channels with fubo tv
want to cut the cord but you're worried
about missing out on live tv
get the best of both worlds with fubo tv
you can watch
live on demand with no bulky setup top
box none of that
the monthly cost of cable is over 200 a
month fubo tv is 65
a month and you can watch the same
channels you don't pay for dvr
none of that stuff all right fubo tv is
how you should be watching tv get
everything you want all in one place
for less than the cost of cable they
have the major
uh broadcast cable network so you can
find all your favorites including
primetime tv
uh and with fubo tv you'll never miss a
game they have nfl
nba mlb nhl ufc premier league
there's no risk to try it out get full
access to fubo tv
seven days free right now fubo tv is
offering you guys seven day free trial
15
off your first month by going to
fubotv.com
fighter there are no contracts and you
can cancel anytime go to fubotv.com
fighter for 15 off your first month in
free trial
that's f u b o t v dot com
slash fighter let me just tell you how
much of our
servant like i called my dad i was like
you failed me as a as an adult
i don't know anything about cars like
changing changing
to youtube how to change a car yeah
change the tire change
yeah i was like who what you're just
going down 405 and you're tired bro
so listen i'm never this is why this is
a real story this is a challenge no no
no no no no this is a real
like my my my trigger is like we get
that we've
grown up with callum podcasting for
seven years yeah i've heard every lie
possible it's not a lie this is not let
me just tell you how
i'm looking like you had a flat tire bro
look on my quest
bro i'm so mad listen let me just say
this why is your hair still good though
well hold on that's that's that good
jean i had to make some crazy did you
scuff the
no no hell no i had flip-flops
no but you got to go barefoot some [ __ ]
you gotta prioritize yeah
listen white off white yeah
yeah do y'all have shoe cam because i
could just put it somewhere
yeah these fans are dope
yeah so so so anyway so i i i call you
i'm like yo
i leave at 11 45 i'm i'm
in mid city l.a right i'm sorry i'm
gonna come in here with a pink drink
cheese danish you know relaxing kick up
here's the thing
i see a jetta on like behind me i'm not
about to merge
over if you have like a lesser car than
me
right fair that's fair right if it's a
man's i'm going to get out cause you got
big stuff
to do respect it but i was like you know
what i'm feeling good bro
so i merge over something black wait
what car are you in
britain let's not say this on the
podcast
you don't know his car let's not okay
you act like you're rolling in the g one
i'm not rolling the goddamn g right here
that's the nissan the the smaller one
the better wait
what time it is they got speed though
they got speed what's this is they got
speed that's pickup though
you got pickup there's alta the
ultimate's the smaller one
what's that whatever the smaller one is
is what he goes it's a central first
it's the center
that's the smallest one those are about
what year
what year does the year matter yeah the
year does matter i mean
it was a graduation card that's cool
2012
it's a collector's house it's a
collector's i don't pay any notes hey
you know
i don't pay any notes because i'll be
asking you for ride thank you
bro once i'm riding around i got a car
what you uber everyone yeah yeah i'm
gonna start doing that but what you
are you yeah bro look at look what all
is listen i didn't know what to do
the first thing i did was call it was
calling call a woman
to change the tires to change the tire i
swear to god
you'll see her in a minute yeah huh she
was she like what the [ __ ] she was like
yo
don't worry i don't know how to change
the tire but we could switch cars
and you can get to where you need to go
i was like i gotta ride or die
is that what happened that's i swear
she's gonna pull up her car okay i took
her car she's literally on the side
waiting for the people to come
yeah that's yeah you know the
the danger of pulling over and changing
a tire your chance of dying go
through the roof really because people
don't see you yeah
wait like like if you're like if you
pull over especially on the highway it's
so dangerous
that's why i was so scared when i did it
so damn i laugh at people oh i don't
laugh i'm like man that's messed up
but then here's the thing i did the
little thing on the side of the road
like how i see in movies
you know the thumbs up i did the thumbs
up that's hitchhike yeah that's hitch
right here i picked up
i didn't know i didn't know i didn't
know you couldn't do that well no no
nobody picked me up but no they're not
getting picked up well i'm not gonna
they're gonna pick you up look at me i'm
offended now yeah they don't pick people
up dog they don't
not anymore people well hitchhike i was
trying to say pull over so you can help
me so i thought that was the same i
would maybe this
oh this is like especially on the 405
oh yeah my [ __ ] my bad it's super
dangerous i'm glad i was almost here
like let's say what if you get someone
that
that thinks you pretty bro come on now
wait wait
wait you you holding your thumb out
there comes over yeah
you got pretty mouth you got a purty
mouth i don't have a where are you
headed yeah put that thumb down
why is that actually going to story
yeah seen the story you take your shirt
off all the time
come on yeah if he goes i just can
finally see your instagram go to his
instagram
wait no wait no we're not doing this
again we're not okay
we're talking like yo what's your name
the funniest instagram
call away does he yeah i mean well i i
just do a little serious about it
yeah i'm a model like model yeah
model right there right there that's a
good picture right now can we be honest
look at me bro look at how elegant yo
that look at anytime santa that's
hilarious exactly
and then listen everyone is around like
brennan and brian y'all was talking
i was like hey come get me right yeah
picture time hey look how elegant i'm
grabbing you
brendan i think stevie did stevie did
stevie no angles
stevie knows his camera but he knows he
doesn't play around the camera listen
oh oh i wish i had to post it we had
like you remember that stairwell
in that lobby right now yeah he made him
have a picture that's the best picture
right there
oh yeah troy conrad got that
bro yeah don't look at that you're the
best hype man when it comes to that [ __ ]
bro look at how you got up bro
i know a lot of people can't do that a
lot of people can't
he got a little bit of my fat you see
that i saw that little rolling i saw
that
i saw a little room in the back yeah
that's all good still doing it
hey you know what i love you you're like
you're like
ellen now now ellen has to dance every
time someone's like alan
dancing
you should get tired it's like she's all
mean and [ __ ] she'll [ __ ] you
now everywhere we go huh everyone's like
dude you can do the back oh yeah
everywhere we go
everyone goes look how big that box is
come on man yeah
come on man that's when jim's was open
now i'm losing weight i don't know my
mom think i'm sick now because she was
like i think people was a game wait were
you out the gym
um wait what's the biggest you've been
valent uh
189 what are you right now she was like
167.
yeah they're they're you're boxing every
day yeah yeah
yes yeah i feel you uh now did you take
that photo i took it uh
january 5th yeah january 5th
in 2012 though no no no no wait no
that's january 12
2009 uh 2012 that's only january damn
yeah okay i know and you're opening for
uh
jeff garland yeah jeff growling that's
cool yeah let's go by the way he's upset
that uh the emmys that
his his tv show didn't uh get uh kirby
enthusiasm
not one award season yeah yeah they
should create science creek wiped
everything out what's [ __ ] scream look
at this
look at this here's
the ladies like malik when we're on the
road the ladies like malik well hello
to my queen that's watching um i don't
know what i don't know what he mean by
that
i don't know what he means to your queen
i don't know i don't know what he's
brother i'm just saying that you're an
attractive dude appreciate that i'm not
saying
do anything thank you you're right
brenden you're right but i'm a queen i
just
know thank you she'll pull up in a
minute wrong side that's what's right
what i changed a [ __ ] time
i changed your goddamn tire and you're
talking about hoes on the road
holes on the road bro that should be an
album i have no pictures like that on my
instagram
no shirtless [ __ ] i thought i took one
shirtless pick when i was keto strict
for like dude
come on bro on a park bench look out
loud look at my box pulled all the way
my socks pulled all the way up because i
was working i did legs that day and i
know you on this podcast
was talking they look big though can we
be honest with that filter they look
strong
oh with that look at that calf muscles
look at that look at that goddamn right
cow you can't tell me
what's in your cap i was flexing
is there more than one oh with the shirt
on so now we got shirt
pictures well here is this guy named mom
he was like bro
he was a guy he was like bro we're gonna
make it pop i said i don't like how you
going
with it but i'm gonna just believe it
make it pop a lot of a lot of
comments from girls on there yeah of
course 720 likes
you keep going up the lights let's okay
can we go up i'll start
nostalgia oh damn if i put that one
first it'll have more like hey look at
this comment
my dude's standing kids summer camp
what the hell is that too crazy i gotta
start blocking people
if you don't fish i gotta start that's
what i'm saying i gotta start blocking
people if you're gonna say something on
that a magnificent pitcher like that
stand my kid somebody oh 100
okay we're gonna ignore the a beautiful
man by alexis the goddess
come on and look at the hard eyes but
but we believe you on the
the flat tire no no i'm just going to
try to get a fact from yeah i thought
maybe you're hanging out with talent
well by the way you pick up things and
and i wouldn't lie to you b
i really when i called you i was like
hey man
i'm stuck i was hoping you was like
don't worry man i got you where are you
i'll send somebody for you but uh well i
see that now i can't send you out to the
middle of 405 right
you can't send chin we got work to do i
was i was hoping i was hoping
yeah yeah look at that one yeah
i had to tell the uber driver you know
pull up
hey i thought uber uh stopped in l.a no
it was but then like
some [ __ ] happened to where i don't know
it's like on like hold right now or
whatever but you can still uber right
now yeah it's still uber because they
were trying to make them
make them employees you got a vote you
got a vote uh
uh what nine zero or something like that
uh that's why he's like yo
four key uber around um as uh
i think they're private independent
industry private contractors yeah you
want to keep them independent
yes that's like give them benefits and
insurance we're out
yeah yeah uber's like [ __ ] this but does
uber have a lot of money they can do it
yeah for sure didn't uber just buy
postmates too like uber's balls uber's
balling
yeah when they were down what did you do
for rides
it wasn't even down that long like
literally they're like we're we're
shutting down tomorrow
and then literally got a message the
next day we're not shutting down
how powerful you gotta be to be like nah
we're not shutting down uber i know
i didn't know what i was gonna do i was
like bro does taxis still exist
yeah they do but they high now oh
they're high bro i rolled in the taxi
from the airport man are you
they're 40. i don't see how they stay in
business like taxis like they're way
more expensive than anybody that's a
different hustle like they have to like
be there yeah be there like wait around
you can download the
why i know so i don't know but you can
download like the taxi app it's kind of
like postmates now
i'm sorry like over now really well
let's go pick you up
it's still more expensive still more so
why would i [ __ ] with them yeah their
prices are
i don't know anyone that takes a taxi i
mean probably with new york
if you don't want to waste new york
there's a shitload of taxis but they're
everywhere like
you just walk outside here and one picks
you up so you don't need uber out there
but here you need uber
if you're gonna get around especially
like you do you know what i'm saying
i know i should just get a car but i'm i
don't and i keep doing it yeah okay
theo went on that honda civic i'm gonna
throw that energy out there do it dog
theo tried doing uber for i think like
four months i was like yeah you got the
amount of money i spent on uber i could
have had my own car
yeah you got a car what you trying to
say to me
no i'm just saying that's that's theo i
don't know where you're going my high
school teacher drive over
uber now really yeah does he still teach
i hope not i'm like yo you you said be
something with yourself and
you were an uber driver and i just
figured he used to [ __ ] on me in high
school really
were you good in school nah well no i
wasn't disrespectful
to the class like i hate it to be a
class clown because if you're going to
learn i'm not about to disrespect you
but i was i was like i go in there i'm
like man this is stupid
i got a class clown i don't know why
you're a voted classical yeah i think i
have a picture of my
idea and you were cheerleading uh no not
when i got the class clown what what
i was just skating and he was just funny
he was all around the front of you but
here's the thing
bro like i didn't i don't i still to
this day have no clue
did you blow them into that no i thought
it was a joke i thought they were making
fun of me here's
the thing with class clown it's either a
good thing you become a comic or you're
just a complete failure
like the class clown there's no in
between well that's true that is yeah
either you're a [ __ ] idiot or you
become a stand-up comic
like there's no middle ground there
right there like the class clown's
either a nightmare or it's
mean you know classic or classical thank
you powell junior high school this is
junior high yeah that's junior
junior high i enjoy making people laugh
wait chappelle yeah that's my real last
name yeah
everyone knows that come on man i'm
sorry i apologize you're right it's been
a minute
no right i'm gonna tell you what i'm
missing the road
oh dude i miss you man i know yeah yeah
because we have so much fun on the road
and then you're the one who got me
started on pink drinks yes sir the
starbucks pink drink you made fun of me
you made fun of me well we were in utah
and
uh i was a camera stopping starbucks so
i'm addicted to coffee i'm like you
won't need anything
because i want a venti pink drink my god
damn it
all right all right so he gets that but
then you wet someone would just dress
into it i'm holding the drink i'm like
well you see what all the fuss is about
took a sip god damn it every day
every day and sends us pictures every
day i love it i love it you love it
you ever you have a problem i have a
problem
they put too much ice in i get the
trenta the trench okay they make you
they make that
now now here's the thing since you've
been posting it on your story or your
instagram i go to my certain spots
sold out i don't know if yeah what kind
of effect you got going on but
big bikes bikes are sold out no you are
drink
is the pure yo it's so refreshing yeah
and it's not it's so much sugar though
it's not though
no it's only like 140 calories really
even on the diet i'm on now i think i
could maybe
pull it off yeah not every day probably
like a you could probably have a smaller
one look up how much
140 calories for 16 ounces
27 grams 24 grams of sugar that's kind
of a lot
yeah at least these 210 calories that is
true especially doing a treat
type in trenta pink drink what am i
dealing with there oh yeah you went you
i mean
you were hard sometimes i have two a day
for real do you go that hard with him
now
he don't post that he just like he just
posted once
you don't post that he had him i'm like
is this starbucks trenta
or something uh yeah starbucks are they
the only ones that go by trintha yes
i feel like they're the only ones that
do that yeah oops
there you go all right let's see this
i just click on the menu see it still
says that's that can't it can't only
arm 40. there's no way 140
they're [ __ ] delicious though yeah i
don't do that
i can't remember the last time i've been
at starbucks though oh i thought it was
a different drink
a trench is a size yeah
270 calories 55 grams that's crazy
damn damn yeah i know
i'm gonna diet now yeah okay sorry i
mean you have it's a bummer
i can't have them now i didn't know that
yeah your calorie intake
like for this diet is one hundred
calories seventeen hundred
starving i had a chicken salad okay
piece of pineapple
all today that's it he said a piece of
pineapple i fast in the morning someone
said
lunch and two snacks and a dinner and
that's it it's all under like 1700
calories
what let's see i got to do something
it's too thick
yeah but you're a thick guy too though i
am a thick guy
yeah what are you gonna do i don't know
i'm pretty scared yeah
i get like all weird about it because
like um i was telling you earlier like
when i cheered
like i was just shredded and like but
but like i didn't realize how fit i was
i didn't you just don't think about it
because you're just you're just doing it
yeah you know what i mean
and then once i stopped like how much
did you weigh
when you were in college when i was in
college i think it was like one
190. shredded shredded mustard but the
thing is you're flipping around all
[ __ ] day you're burning calories
it's just a different and that's like
your job yeah your job now i don't need
to be
[ __ ] flipping you know yeah but i
mean i at least want to like i mean i
have a gut
i ain't going to show nobody i ain't you
but i have a good yeah
i mean i want to like get better and
like ever since i started cooking i'd
just be cooking
i know shut up yeah yeah
that's your title doug i get i'm getting
chunky dude my brand's
thick boy yeah i can't be skinny boy
no you can't i'm not trying i don't want
to be skinny i don't want to get i don't
want to be
i don't want to get down to 190 again
i'm 250 right now hey i got what's wrong
with being
190's not in our future bubba oh no even
if you wanted i can accept that yeah
this isn't your future well yeah but it
isn't that i accept that 190 is not in
my
so you're how much you weigh right now
250 me too
thanks about 256. hell yeah bro i
appreciate i'm 256. but i'm also
six for chappelle you're how tall
i'm just saying why did you like that
that was i saw it i saw all right i saw
all that going down he said i saw it all
go down
he was like oh let me crush a soul right
well 250 is different on bodies you know
so you're
well you're short in compact you like a
bite size snickers yeah yeah
you're everybody letting it grow i like
you thicker though like my girl doesn't
like yeah i get real skinny she
appreciates my thickness she likes the
thickness yeah
is your girl thick no skinny i wonder
wait time out does that
i wonder how like if you're a fig girl
and a big boy together how does that
work how's that
what's up you talking about a fat couple
what
i didn't want to say it's all my
favorite goddammit
they're called fat couples and they're
everywhere they're everywhere
hey and you know what and god bless them
[ __ ] they get fat together
we got a friend who had a chubby girl
come on man come on come on man come on
come on come
so you i tell a story oh that's my alarm
i'm about to say wow wait is that your
alarm yeah peter gabriel salisbury hill
it's a great song wow um oh yeah but we
had a friend who had a uh
friend show up and he goes yeah go ahead
he was bragging i'm like an
album but he goes he's bragging as my
queen's here and i'm like oh i gotta see
her dude
we have a rule he can't have people in
the green room so he's like she's in the
back there
so i poked my head out i was like
bro you talking about moana against the
walden
i said queen you talking about dairy
queen back
you call it a dairy queen
i was like oh and that's where the
norwich chicks were you know yeah yeah
yeah you're like cause she he was like
yo i'm pretty you want to drink
anything she was like dude they got the
menu
and next thing you know we come back out
and i see brittany
she got like this big plate of fries
curly fries curly curly i didn't know
they had curly fries not either i didn't
know
she fought the box is the only place i
know that's making curls you said so
you're saying she's poor she's gay
curly fries she's actually she forced
she looks like tough girl that carries
ranch in her purse you know those girls
they have france and they're first
shout out to that queen god bless that
queen shout out
shout out to his ranch queen shout out
to love shout out to love
there was no love there because she was
a bit of an [ __ ] it was i heard yeah
he came back there
yeah i went to like get a drink and i
guess she was like all extra and he's
like
i'm the cash man i'm the price
i'm the prize i'm like listen there's
thick and then it's i was like she's
unhealthy
you know like it's like she's unhealthy
dude yo brandon
god it was so funny because the next day
we all kept quiet
and then you just start unloading i got
them built up but i don't want to do it
in front of them
i sit in the green room like oh my god
the next day someone just said something
i was like
oh because we're going bike ready that's
right oh yeah and then we're in the car
for
40 minutes i was like hey dude how about
that fat chick and then it was just like
off to the races you did not stop after
that
it was so fun it was so [ __ ] he was
like man brendan mick
and then jacob in the back he has hate
so we're all sold on merch
oh we got all we got left is that triple
x he goes
does your girl want it he's just out
there
he just bleep that name he just outed
him
i mean you can figure it out though if
it's not you guys yeah i'll figure it
out i know right yeah
let's just look at the group photo
you're like
there's only one there's only one here
that's just these guys are all taken
what about that one dude
god bless them though god bless you yeah
yeah it makes us fun
yo why not yeah hell yeah cause he he's
consistent with it
because this is consistent i'm proud of
him
i'm like the real life norbit he really
is man respected
man bike riding was so hard bruh
well y'all were nervous about me yes
why you're a bigger guy
and then you're on bikes yeah but i do
backflips that is true
yeah i know but we didn't skateboard to
be fair
to be fair to be fair you was going like
five miles per hour
yeah i know because i know my limit i
know what i'm well you guys went from
zero to it's like yeah you know it's
it'd be like you're five minutes
skateboard before and then you drop me
off at venice [ __ ]
park you know and i gotta go down the
ramp but everything's zero to 100 like
you guys didn't just
bike ride you went on like yeah we were
going pretty fast and i was
listen i was like i'm not trying to
impress anybody i respect my speed see
there's me it's me jay and stevie right
there if you scroll
no not well oh the scooter game scooter
guy scooter gang i was so mad i wasn't
there man
scooter game with justin if you scroll
up chen it's
it's up right all right that's it but we
were
far ahead look how strong you were y'all
did the tougher
yeah the course tougher course dude and
uh we tried to pick that bike up i try
to do it like how you take pictures that
day
tired that friends like hit me in my
head almost got a concussion yeah that's
it that's a heavy you're a strong guy
bro then when we were on the ski line
yeah
oh the ski light oh my god oh you guys
went i'm so mad
we didn't know what we didn't been on a
ski lift before i'm so mad at you i'm so
glad
i'm mad at you because you you you for
one you jay and stevie
have all the experience right y'all did
this before me
okay okay okay that's fair me chappelle
are you looking for a video chat yeah
um go to justin's page yeah he has a
picture
yeah justin ate it what is justin uh
justin uncut
uncut yeah right there okay so his
picture
uh go down right that's right there i
tried to pick it up like i'm ready let
me just go ahead and get the little
hell no hell no i don't got it like him
all right
bro it hit me in the back of my head man
i ain't doing this [ __ ] again hell i
don't know how i read it
first of all those were the two those
two ate it and y'all were worried about
it
i didn't i didn't eat it i didn't eat it
like that let's just eat it
you didn't have dirt on your clothes
because i was looking for adjustments
and when justin ate it it was so sad he
flew up in the air and then
i wish you guys got that
because no let me can i set it up justin
what he wanted to be
you he wanted to be the captain of our
crew he was like every time we're like
yo come on let's ride
oh
little do they know he ate it on a bike
why his eyebrows like that like why he
confused like why
you take a picture of me right now look
at this the first the first count goes
you look constipated
but you okay question mark with three
two questions
why they do i'm like yo he says you get
a better verse
everything flew out his pocket his
partner passed his id the twenty dollars
i tried to scoop up
he he did and and he listen i stopped
for him yeah alex just was like
you know i had to it was so funny
because he wanted to be he wanted to be
the leader
he wanted to be the leader of the game
he didn't even know he was bleeding yet
i just go hey man you got something on
your arm
because i didn't want to say you got a
bloody arm because he was like man i'm
good you're like
you got something on your arm but his
arm was like and his leg and his leg and
his leg
yeah damn yeah i'm not i'm not doing
that again
i'm not doing that yeah i don't need it
yeah yeah i don't know oh you know what
we're gonna do in dallas to shoot guns
i could do that man that's more of my
i'm familiar with that really yeah we're
shooting get both you are
yeah oh damn yeah i'm from arizona man
that's true
yeah we're shooting with uh
you're good
beast he was on rogan smart dude
that's a guy right there man wait so
how'd you two meet
me and brittany yeah i threw brian
through brian oh
cause you opened up for brian yep and
then
for you what show was well no but then
we did san antonio we all did san
antonio
no the first the first one we did was
houston we did houston
oh that's right yeah yeah yeah killed it
and then i was like damn i need that
energy at my show
so then there was an opening and then
damn it
with me bro when you gave me that text i
literally i ain't gonna lie to you
like i was in bed i was like man you
called me i called you
i called him i was like yo britney said
he's like i
i can't wait yeah it's gonna be fun oh
man yeah dallas for me
have you done dallas addison yeah i've
never been in it you've done alice in
there
have you done hyenas too out there i've
not done hyenas
i know where hyenas is i've never done
hyenas the only reason i'm hyena is
because tim dillon
last time i was in dallas i did his
podcast he came to my
uh hotel to do it but i was like you're
out here too i was like what are you
doing he's like hyenas
it's a pretty cool spot yeah yeah down
like i think it's like
dallas is dallas i love texas love texas
love it i still want to move there man
what about one of my favorite place
states that i've lived in is texas by
far by far
food hospitality everything everything
i've got mommy's
dallas is dope for comedy houston's dope
san antonio
austin great dude i did houston
no it was like some like speakeasy type
thing that was it was pretty dope and uh
i was talking to one of the dudes and
like they get time out there really
he was like yeah he goes on a spot he
goes i could do like four or five shows
a night if i want to four five spots
yeah it wouldn't be a bad move yeah
shout out to your boy power wall
houston rep paul wall man he's the real
dallas is dope though because you can do
the jfk
uh shooting uh tour i lived i lived
there
two and a half years i never did that
tour wait wait where's what's that
what's the what what do you mean uh jfk
assassin in dallas and you can go on the
exact tour they take you on his path
where he was assassinated yeah
here's the problem with that though
definitely was an inside job the
government was involved with it
but when you go i know i sound like sam
tripoli right now but if you go on the
tour
it's just a little bit of propaganda
where they they say you know that guy
uh harvey lee oswald was the single
shooter yeah yeah
you know he's not so it's tough but i'm
looking
and if there is uh email uh the firing
kids shop at gmail.com
or dm me uh if if there's a conspiracy
tour
because the government tour is lame oh
really
yeah i'm dying to do that we should
definitely do it saturday we'll shoot
guns friday we should do this let's do
it
why not what's the letter jfk oh there
actually is the tour so it says
oh wow that's what you want they talk
about jack ruby his involvement
the new orleans connection yeah that'd
be sick
you look deep into that conspiracy stuff
do you if they're legit ones like this
but not like the flatter you do that gee
what about the 911 somebody told me it
was
pretty
well i'm intrigued me too like a lot of
times i think especially get
big because it's better than the truth
yeah yeah like people want to believe
something bigger than what actually
happened
with this they look into it it's like
come on man it's pretty easy yeah yeah
also trump released a lot of the
paperwork the documentations
but he goes i can't release all of it
because i don't want to alarm the public
so what are we talking about man come on
man and then there's a million books on
it a million books yeah i never get into
that stuff man it's a little
it's heavy like september 11th i don't
it's just too heavy it's too dark
yeah this one's fun i like it oh okay
it's also a bomber though you know
that's what i'm saying that's why i
can't get into this stuff
well you're right well i mean you like i
said youtube is a crazy place
so once you i i get too deep into it
like the whole
sex kid ring and uh
was it cute pizzagate the pizzagate
stuff like that
but when i was in dc i went to where
pizzagate was at and i talked to the
owner
you could tell he just he's like
business is booming because we got so
much attention he's like like
you wouldn't know about this place if
that didn't happen so that's good
money-wise he's like
you could tell like it's family-owned
like he's exhausted oh really
wait there's a there's a restaurant i'm
not getting into it no you can't
see i'm saying that's not easy is that
cosmo's
pizza or something like that's right
that's how i got like but you go to it
and you it's like an older white dude
owner
and and i go yeah everyone's talking
about the basement stuff like that and
he's like oh basement
he's like come with me and took me he's
like where's the [ __ ] the basement
he's like we have this for storage
where's the basement brendan
i was like damn dude i didn't start it i
know right but the food was great oh
food's great
dc food they're connected because they
make pizza yeah
this is in dc comet ping pong pizza yeah
right outside dc
by the way dc is great for comedy one of
the best shout outs to new balances they
wear a lot of that
they wear new balances east coast does
yeah east coast they don't do vans
nah they don't do you can you put that
now yeah they'll they'll do that they'll
do vans i need a new pair
so uh but so they provide pizza to a lot
of the
the public officials that's how they got
caught up in this and the next door to
them
is a like child day care center
so it's like they put two and two
together they provide pizza for
government officials and hillary clinton
and but here's the they make really good
pizzas
you're rattling my brain right now i
know this is how you get this high
i can't do it right next if you want you
can connect the dots it will make sense
yeah if you want it to black it's dark
[ __ ] and then i got kids when we talk
about
pedophilia yeah yeah yeah that's why i
got caught bro black guy told me all
about the conspiracy theories
which one like well he was telling me
about like the 911 and he was just
getting like come on use your hands
yeah the towers come on you really think
i was like bro all i want to buy is some
incense
just trying to buy it i'm just trying to
buy some trying to support you
the problem is like it's never like an
incredible source that you never yeah
there's like some crazy lunatic on the
corner yeah
some crazy youtuber guy yeah i can't
yeah i can't do it
i can't do it certain ones i can i just
find like i believe i'll just read my
spiritual
books i'll just stick with that do you
believe in the mediums and [ __ ] though
no
no don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] sorry that
was aggressive yeah it was
hell it wasn't christmas it was one of
the posters we i want you
we want you so you don't believe in the
mediums or any of that
i don't i don't roll with this stuff
there's a way they can do it though the
media i don't know yeah
because i don't know i just listen i
just just
let me live my life please you know what
i mean like i don't like to
like i don't need to know this random
like
i don't know i just like to live i don't
need to know things and
yeah it's always weird because those
mediums are like especially
entertainment like you're gonna land a
big role
i don't know when i'm like yeah thank
you for that yeah yeah
that's a fortune cookie well i guess but
see what what that does is like that
gets to your head and you like start
looking for this [ __ ] it's like oh the
number nine is a unique thing for you
all of a sudden you're looking for nines
but you are already like if you're in
business you're the
entertainment business you already think
you're going to land the big gig yeah
so if that might help somebody stay with
it i guess i don't know you believe in
that like 11 and 11 make a wish and
stuff like that
and no i don't know that yeah no got me
on that one time i believe in some good
luck how long were you into it for
like for two weeks i was like 11 11 make
a wish and then i
kept doing it huh but two and all of
those two weeks two times i lost twenty
dollars
i'd never make a wish again did you have
any like uh
uh what do you call it like when you
were fighting did you have any rituals
no no
oh well yeah well yeah i just i if i
have to put on my cup
before i get my hands wrapped that was
my ritual that was it it was weird
i wanted to sit down want to sit down
with my cup while i get my hands wrapped
and that was i always wanted my right
hand wrapped first but it was never like
and then i remember when i was doing
golden gloves i'd always put my right
hand in first
and they forced me to put my left hand
first i'm like ah [ __ ]
wait and then i knocked the guy out and
that doesn't matter yeah yeah right
you realize that [ __ ] but it's a comment
when you go to the right hand first
though
usually everyone puts the right hand
first yeah but then i was like yeah
forever and golden gloves they would
just like some dude get knocked out he'd
take his gloves off we would share
gloves
so then what a reason he was like yo and
only had the left hand i'm like
you didn't want to look at it like i was
like goddammit
have you ever seen his fights no ufc 253
is this
weekend get involved all right you bet
one dollar you can win 100
if you pick the right fighter style
bender or costa
whoever you think is going gonna win bet
one dollar you get 100
with draftkings sportsbook it's giving
all new users the chance
to turn one dollar into 100 that's right
one dollar you bet on either headline
fighter and if that fighter wins you
cash a cool
100. how can you pass that up if you're
new to draftking sportsbook
head to the app right now scout their
latest offers draftkings is safe
reliable secure making it easy for you
to deposit withdraw your money
whenever you want download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code fighter when you sign
up to get this can't miss offer pick
either headlining fighter style bender
or costa
during ufc 253 you bet one dollar you
can win
100 if you pick the right fighter that's
one dollar to win one hundred dollars
when he's the right promo code fighter
during sign up for limited time only at
draftking sportsbook
must be 21 and older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler or
in indiana 1-809 with it then i knocked
the game
have you ever seen his fights nah bro
he's got a funny one on youtube where
he's just talking [ __ ]
the whole time to some dude and even
he's even talking [ __ ] to uh
the dude's trainers what what really
he's like yeah i'm in great shape
go to youtube go to youtube go to
youtube
i think it's like mark oh yeah the more
guy i'm in great shape
hey for one let's just talk to talk
about the promotion company
they they they uh oh wow look
at wait look hold on look at myself
look at my dad
i'm very anxious for this fight tomorrow
i'm as a mustache
on that fight 153 i was going through
something fighting
153 yeah 153 mentally prepared
physically
smart basically why they call you mark
well i don't know the promotion company
was like yo
like you know what we think mark we
realized i was like what's your name
malik malik i was like no
malice let me see his opponent oh carl
carl
carl killed me car killed me his intro
was waving oh [ __ ] yeah yeah hurry up
turn it off he killed me
i'm coming from compton california i'm
coming out here you know i'm ready to
turn up
well this is so difficult this is i
don't know why y'all doing this
because it was hilarious
oh he killed me with the intro look at
his intro music oh
lean back with it carl oh no his intro
watch his intro
for one that's that's i i wasn't
prepared for it i didn't know how that
was going back
he killed me you remember this song we
have to cut the music which sucks
oh yeah yeah we cut it yeah yeah he came
out killed bro he's ready he's ready for
me
i know i was scared as hell is this pro
yeah now this is an exhibition
oh okay was this in vegas this was
actually in uh
way up north in california uh i want to
say clemente all right what is it
clementine san clemente he's in good
shape and he hates it i don't even give
you nothing don't give me an intro
anything outside
that's what you get from santa clamente
look
while my mouth is like that my
mouthpiece didn't really it was a
last-minute training for this fight
without training yeah where um
actually be honest i'm not trying to
sound cocky i didn't train for this
fight you didn't train for this fight
no because like it was the last minute
exhibition like hey we're putting on his
like great benefit for charity or
something like that
you want to be a part of it look at the
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's slow because he
yeah because he was talking i didn't
like honestly he had i didn't like his
head
is why the shorts are so baggy it's so
strange
yeah those are like why wouldn't you
want to move it
it's flashier now look this is what in
2012 though
this flash here now like you see like
earl smith or do you stop it no no no no
no
no
no
what's in this dude i kind of yeah we
can fast forward but uh i walk on this
one says
wait a minute okay you're for real i
literally fighting for this whole fight
but yeah it's just me talking i was like
all right well cause cause i wasn't in
shape and i was like this dude is big
and he's strong and he like i guess he
uh
he from compton what you want me to do
then throw a lot of punches
no he doesn't oh he doesn't know i'm
throwing one punch this entire seat but
he didn't i'm so thankful he did
brilliant
true god again the confidence but that
was it yeah that was a whole and on one
uh we won the exhibition and uh i was
like yo
after the fight he was like bro he
really wanted to fight true story
oh you have to fight like afterwards
yeah i was like wait like i was like bro
that's forbidden it's for charity
like nah man no it's crazy
yeah i fast forward to uppercut all the
way at the end i hit him with a good
uppercut and i think that's what like
they
uh was this corner talking [ __ ] yeah we
were talking
both of the corners yeah and it was
funny i was like bro this is for chair
because you were like i'm in great shape
i mean
yeah yeah uh great shape they said
he's coming up he's coming up what did
they shout at you they were like he
ain't in shape he ain't in shape he was
like yo
he ain't throw punches i was like well
by the way
all wearing beanies and say turn up wait
which is yeah that's that's hard just
[ __ ] weird my quarter my corner he
had dreads i was like okay we not we
didn't look at
good as a oh here i think it's coming
right here right here with the uppercut
i'm sorry this dude throwing punches
he hitting me right now you know what
oh this is the one right here this the
one right here this is the one right
here wait wait wait
that that this is the one that wanted me
to fight right here oh
listen come on
i don't know what my legs rewind yeah
that was they did a little choo-choo
train but
look at that then watch them look
that's hilarious i don't know why my
legs are what you're doing
watching my legs i think i wanted to
walk over there but my legs was like
hold on let's take a second
and then his corner started talking [ __ ]
he's talking he was like yo he tired for
real now
look at his legs i was like wait no i
think it was
and that was that was that was the end
of the fight solid that was
that that wanted me to hair stuff yo he
really wanted to fight me out though she
was like yeah what you saying in the
ring i was like bro that was in the ring
that's hilarious afterwards
huh and they want to fight you out yeah
they wanted to fight so the corner
because remember the coroners was
talking
to each other non-stop and it's always
weird when they want to fight after
afterwards i'm like bro he was like have
you heard that uh
no no no never will you finish him
you fail but still it'd be like we get
paid to do this why would i do it for
free out here
yeah true yeah makes no sense i was like
bro you got all these good ass white
people in the crowd don't make a
decision
come on man don't do that don't do that
bro i'm trying to get a business deal i
don't know if it's in uh
current events cap but that that jerry
guy from chair
you hear about him i just got a bad
judge of character because he was my
favorite
dude on that netflix series chair do you
know what i'm talking about yeah did you
watch jared
oh he oh he got you going to jail dude
they're looking at like
years 12 to 14 years in jail so he
texted a younger guy
i don't know what exactly happened do
you cat um you said it
last time i checked it was apparently he
was meeting up with
younger kids between the ages of like 13
to 15 at cheer competition and how old
was he at the time
27 like 19. can't be doing that
yeah apparently he was like trying to
solicit nudes and get them to do
sexual favors for him and he but he was
america's
[ __ ] sweetheart because he was on
ellen
because he's so positive he did
something with the oscars
and oscars he was like the the like
sideline reporter for the oscars
yeah didn't you do that i did that how
was it
he did it for e i think for a bunch like
i did oh
grammy's academy awards oscars uh
american music
awards for e but why was i at a table
it was like a garden oh you didn't do
what he did no you weren't like
hey what's up i'm not mario lopez you
know what i'm saying like i was i was at
a desk
mario lopez be boxing in the wildcard
i thought of skills yeah he nice he cool
yeah cool but i mean trains all the time
yeah yeah
all the time but he's not like no yeah
i went in there with him listen let's
let's not let's not i wanted to
stop it stop i want it
come on come on tell the true story skip
come on
he swung at me and i screamed he
screamed the whole gym
listen when the whole gym stopped and
the music was playing
and they was like wait what the hell's
going on like like what what woman is
tripping in this
he i was like wait wait don't do that i
was like not a chappelle this is
nobody were you trying to box to lose
weight
huh i was trying the boxes i wanted to
try it out see if like i can actually do
something you know
and uh no not for you
you started doing kickboxing didn't you
try jiu jitsu too yeah
how was that yeah like it was fine do
you love it or no
i like muay thai better i if you're
trying to like get results fast like
lose weight
muay thai or boxing's the way to go
jitsu takes years dude yeah it's a b
like you know when he goes sign up for
jiu jitsu's like [ __ ] dude you're
looking at a 10-year plan
yeah so you said don't go to the same
planet
no you can't go if you want if you want
to learn jitsu that's a great place to
go
or you know the grace academy in
torrance but you're looking at a
long commitment if you're trying to like
lose weight i wouldn't say that's the
best route to go
okay like kickboxing or yeah because i
can't do i mean
i can't like i can't i wonder if i could
make a cheer team again i probably could
you can't you think you probably could
if you can't if i if i'm coaching him if
yeah yeah if i got him on my house
get up there brittany get up get up
just me and chappelle just the thickest
chair the stick is what oh no y'all got
it y'all got it okay
you know hella giving out we got our
boys big girl yeah
we got it we got a longest yard oh yeah
yeah she was like we made a trip for you
we got a chip give me that eye
give me that seat see all right okay
yo yo that's so funny though tyler's
like all right
all right that's like what you said out
last night upon trail oh yeah
it's like all right wait we don't need
anything it's not you were saying last
night
oh that's why your breasts felt like
eight cans of shark [ __ ]
yeah tracy morgan's so [ __ ] funny so
funny dude look at him yo
he's so good yo that's so funny imagine
you be in the background
how funny was that yo that's so look at
uh they put him up next to uh
ezekiel elliott oh yeah that's so funny
zeke so
funny but don't don't why he had a
little
teardrop dude i just realized that no
not anymore i thought football players
did he does it and then he also got a
tattoo across the stomach that i think
says feed me
oh that's just thank you yeah yeah it
was like this like feed me the rock
oh really i wish i want comics to have
like uh like if we have like a big ass
punch line like you know how lebron do
this
i think make a yeah we should have like
after a joke hit
we should just be like man try it out in
dallas let me know how it goes i'm gonna
do something i'm gonna do it do the
whole i'm gonna do the whole thing oh
yeah brother i don't know come on come
on
exactly i say the punch line do you feel
me or what you can do with the rock dude
bro raise your eye bro you do something
or do it like uh off an orbit dave
chappelle or i'm not
another professor what did you get a
good punchline you start dancing are you
turning around
so rich that guy rick yeah he's reggie
yo mama
yeah i was watching something that came
on tv that day that i didn't know dave
chappelle was in
uh it was like it was a wee movie he's
great oh
half baked half bait you know bread and
wrote yeah he did yeah
oh bro that's so funny i had me crying
about that
i did not know about that movie bro you
gotta keep it high
man they get you hot i was like bro this
is hard though the rapper smoke a lot
start smoking like the rapper man they
get you hot crazy is that movie didn't
do
like when it came out like it was it
didn't flop but it became like a cold
huge faucet like it made neil brad never
want to work in hollywood
because yeah like the movie got
destroyed in the box office bray was so
funny
so great yeah it's a classic now me
stick by my story
[Laughter]
nate in there if i was in jamaica and
then why would i wear this at well
right down by the beach
that's my guy right there hell yeah sir
smoke a lot dude
[ __ ] great bro where he came one yeah
neil yeah
neil brendan wrote that he did he's a
genius
that do the gosh um who
the white dude to the brewer jim brewer
yeah jim brewer
favorite guest he opens up for like uh
for like metallica and [ __ ] yeah brew
he does his act outs man like he's
watching he's got high energy watch his
older stuff
monster yeah jim brewer's a [ __ ]
monster
one of my favorite guests on here of all
time oh really
oh you had him on here yeah that's so
dope jim brewer's [ __ ] great
damn he was such a good guest man before
do current events let me take a piss
okay all right go take a piss what's up
bring before what's the bring up top uh
barbecue spots in dallas
come on man come on come on come on come
on come on
skip where are we going in dallas man
madison
got i'm gonna oh we're like oh i was
like oh we're gonna oh no
dude the first off the pecan uh lodge is
world famous because you went there last
year didn't you yes
fire yeah and lockhart smokehouse
uh barbecue also world famous thick
stuff
slow bone also really good but uh we
usually go the pecan lodge or the
uh lock hearts what's that lockhart's
to me is better than pecan lodge but
they're both great and they're all i'll
tell you what truth barbecue and i think
houston beats them all
yeah yeah i wouldn't i wish i would've
ate that one
so we're going to what we're going this
yeah we go lockhart
hutchins number one that's beautiful
damn i'm gonna gain
150 minimum they'll deliver it's a what
uh it says for a hundred fifty dollar
minimum they'll deliver a care package
a care package brisket sausage size
between malik you
me jay yeah we can do that come on we
can use that come on skip it's only one
fifty
only one fifty damn those other ones
aren't on there but is this
dallas this is barbecue
that's gonna be i get one cheat meal a
week this will be my cheat meal okay one
okay smoked meat but you gotta choose
yeah
yeah uh i mean i'm probably there every
day i don't care
yeah i don't have any cheapness out the
window huh do the diet with me
yeah might as well might as well you got
to tell me what it is though
my mouth is watering um yeah
my mouth is [ __ ] up you only can eat
at this spot
once the whole weekend i can yeah what i
mean he he
he can as well yeah i'm funny yeah i
mean once i'll do this
yeah dude yeah well that's whack because
everybody gonna follow a suit and then
i'm like
well we'll eat there you say eat there
on friday or saturday yeah the rest of
time just do whatever
yeah well guys
people ask i think josh wolfe said if
you can pick one
one type of food what would you pick i
said american because the barbecue
a good barbecue there ain't nothing
better
baby back ribs a nice brisket come on
man i'm talking to you mexican food
you too near me not to hear me you need
to hear me out
here
what sauce the barbecue huh that doesn't
make sense right that doesn't make any
sense because if you have
that one before yeah come on now
see there's pecan lodge yeah there are
two of them here so far hmm
gosh but number go back to number one
yeah we're gonna have a blast
my mouth is watering i know dude oh my
gosh so that's where we're going
hutchins okay well we can also we can
look forward to i like going there
feeling the vibe i've cooked it
that's beautiful you know what i can't
stand though is the long lines and all
that [ __ ]
it's like disney world can we call are
you serious wait what is it
like pecan lodge me and jay got there
they open at 10 a.m we got there at 10
a.m we waited probably an hour
yeah we got to do something we got to do
something i know like let's let's go
when someone reaches out like just let
us know i let them know smoking lacy's
just coming through come on let them
know man come on come on skip
you got you got me i'm be i'll be doing
this all weekend let me know if any of
them reach out
okay yeah i'll let you know that'd be
great hutchins is the place
i think i owe somebody in uh money in
dallas i don't know yet
he'll find out yeah come up to the show
like hey bro that was funny with that 20
dollars
you real funny man i appreciate your
comedy but yeah
some of the sides too it's all about the
sides man nice potato salad
what's your favorite i not like cheese
nice potato salad okay okay
you want to know something truth barbie
guys like that uh they do like their
hash brown
mix things fantastic i don't like
macaroni and cheese
that's fair what never have never liked
it never liked it
it don't matter if it's like what
barbecue the best
i've never liked it i can't get into it
that's when your sides turn your meal
when you have the macaroni cheese and
the beans and you just put it together
that can be
if you eat just the meat i never feel
good if i eat just
meat and with no sides i i i always feel
heavy
that that's what like my family i i'm
not even making this up
i can't do fries with all that go ahead
i was just looking at i'm sorry i like
to take the fries
and mop up the barbecue sauce now wait
wait wait wait wait oh you talking about
mcdonald's fries
in the milk down the boat nope what
you're talking about we're talking about
i'm talking about nice barbecue plates
if they have a nice
cut fry i like to take the fries and dip
in the barbecue sauce barbecue
here's a hot take barbecue tastes better
with your fries than ketchup
pickles so what my family at the family
of union what puts ketchup on his fish
tacos
you do that's what you supposedly known
each other for a minute
really mm-hmm when i first moved out
here
i was the first person yeah first person
i met yeah oh wow yeah i didn't know
that
was that a show together yeah some show
running all right
all so awful though and well i i just
had got all three yeah i was like yo i
was like hey bro i just zach was my
first word so i was like hey you do the
a cheer stuff that's for real he's like
yeah i used to be a cheerleader
that's what's up yeah and then i was
like bro
i was like literally no one was laughing
at his [ __ ] nobody was laughing that
which is crazy because he was crap
he was cracking me up he was saying like
the most ruthless craziest
[ __ ] i was right the crowd wasn't
feeling it no it wasn't dark it was just
like i was like it wasn't dark it was
just like he was just talking [ __ ] i was
because i was going through a time where
i used to steal out of women person help
them look for the money
later and i i would i say that on stage
and i'm like and they were not they
weren't feeling right
but that's a true story you know how
hard it is to look for something that
you already know is in your pocket
that's hilarious
it was hilarious i was like you're all
so mad that it wasn't feeling the truth
i had a guy i was i was getting a venti
or
probably a trenta pink drink at
starbucks other day yeah because you do
stand up probably he goes i saw you at
the comedy store man
yeah i thought it was funny man no one
else is laughing though
you're doing some political jokes now
you're breaking it down like
what joking i was like i don't remember
that no one was laughing as i was though
i'm like [ __ ] drinking my [ __ ]
drink is that a disclaimer
i go yeah it's probably a noob that i
was trying i guess yeah i don't know
what it was
so you got a creepy drink right yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] pink dream
i say a lot ice light ice all right what
do you got chin
oh that's so funny chin but you grew up
in texas you know good barbecue right
but it was in central texas though so
away from the big cities
so my family made really good barbecue
the cousin
ooh yeah i found my own yeah she makes
an amazing brisket yeah
i like brisket all right so
a couple days ago there was a charity
event online where a bunch of
celebrities were doing a table read of
fast times at ridgemont high and shia
shia labeouf had a role and he went
super method and since his character was
a stoner he was smoking the entire time
and
here are some clips he's amazed man
that's just him the entire time
two seconds two seconds he was just
be in character though right uh yeah
it's not giving a [ __ ]
damn well that's a character like a
stoner yeah
and sean penn is laughing at him the
entire time and you're redoing fast
times at richmond high
yeah as a table read you know if you're
a yellowstone fan you know
uh the the main guy my favorite rip was
in that movie
rip from yellowstone is in fast times
enrichment high
wow he's like the badass in in
yellowstone he's like everyone's
favorite character his real name's rip
no that's his character in yellowstone
but he was also he's the funny brother
in the breakup with vince vaughn where
he's like i would like to what i want to
do is take saran wrap
oh this guy's a g i love this dude great
actor yeah he's a great actor
what are you oh that's him he played uh
he's also in a higher learning
he's the one of the nazis we were higher
learning of course michael rappaport
was in it too yeah yeah he was one of
the uh neo-nazis he
that oh that is i love that dude yo
he's great in yellowstone wow by the way
so different
looking so different yeah that's crazy
his actual name
uh okay
says ryan with an eye he's rip wheeler
ryan johnson brian johnson he's from
california
that's not him that is not type in uh
rip wheeler
yep real name there you go cool
yeah and you said higher learning yeah
higher learning
oh use that guy in fast and furious
oh yes he's so fast and fierce i
remember this now too yeah yeah him
right he's
crazy he's pretty different yeah well
rappaport
character is crazy in that movie too
there's a cool voice too yeah
he is he's so good in yellow
completely different he's so good the
one with uh eva mendes
he's the uh guy who she was dating
oh that it bro he's this guy he changes
his faces
yeah dude he looks so bad in
the tv show yeah that's how great it is
yeah that jacket right there yeah it
does
that's that say you won't say you won't
rock it in texas i'll rock that chin
texture i'll rock that guy
for texas and be the yellowstone cover
let's go what's up
talk to you well [ __ ] come on then i'm
going
i need to check it out man come on rip
because my favorite one of my favorite
movies is tombstone
you'll love this i love it yeah you'll
love this love that [ __ ] it's my
favorite tv show of all time
really damn i got to check it out
brittany you said that a lot no not
this is for reals okay it makes you want
to move now like you watch
power come on man come on man i can't
get tyree to power
tyree come on tyree you're doing too
much you're doing too much me and
jake get into the discussion yeah what
day's all about it we have this group
chat of
malik chappelle me justin stevie yeah
and then
jay and malik will take it over with
take over either [ __ ] power talk
that nobody else watches
or arguing over lebron or arguing over
lebron and the laker yeah
i just want to know like you guys
podcast and get us the [ __ ]
chat hey yo we're not separated
hates lebron with a passion yes i love
lebron and here's the thing
what he doesn't have any valid reason on
why he hates lebron
he's like he's a jordan guy yes that's
the only reason but that's not valid
enough that's that's just a guy who used
to wear 23 in chicago
lebron was for a long time my favorite
player now he's getting on my nerves
what yeah he's getting my bro you don't
understand like how he's shaping a d
it's crazy by the way for him to have
that game he had last night and just to
find out a couple of days before his son
smokes weed
undefeated undefeated he was mad at
somebody he was mad at his
yeah he he like he had to address the
public he's i don't feel like talking
about this
and they try to like keep talking to him
what about your son are you a good
father and he literally like man
good father he's 13 or 15 15 15.
by the way they're ballers you've seen
this girl you're a sierra canyon he's a
he's a baddie come on wearing dad's
lebron james i'm sure you can get some
hot chicks yeah
brony brownie brown that's what he did
that's what they call him brownie
because his other son's a super baller
right or is it bro
no ronnie ronnie is the baller yeah
that's the bro that's the one that go to
uh sierra hills
sierra canyon sarah king i'm sorry i
said heels you know what i'm thinking of
chino hills willow
lonzo ball and oh word uh put it
together cause i was a big
big baller brand big baller brand so
dave chappelle won an emmy and
his acceptance speech was posted online
he basically said
[ __ ] up foreign
yes you want emmy's first uh special
yeah his most recent one
boy hey let me go this comes as a
complete surprise
what do you say it was a complete
surprise meaning like you want
i mean i read all the reviews and they
said so many terrible things
that cell phone is so funny i lost my
way
it wasn't even worth watching i hope all
you critics
learn from this this is a teachable
moment shut
the [ __ ] up forever that's great yeah
that's what it got that's hard 100
percent respect
all the way i like that all the way he's
doing shows
non-stop at his ranch in ohio non-stop i
know
a girl from florida uh florida comic
went down there and
uh louie she said louis perform killed
it
oh ck yes yeah he said he's just like
it's so fun out there he has it like
organic i was like man
i wonder how many people it is though
yeah i wonder how many people they live
in there
that's a great question yeah i don't
know but it looks
they've been calling it dave chappelle's
summer camp or something like that so
dope so dope
i respect that i love that man yeah shut
the [ __ ] up forever
yeah get a t-shirt that should be merch
shut the [ __ ] up forever
like but not for all the critics that
not only the writers but also the fans
too we're talking all that
[ __ ] yeah everyone talking all that [ __ ]
non-stop
did you guys watch the video yesterday i
did not because let me guess there's a
whole political that people would want
to be like you gotta vote
we gotta do the shot with it yeah shut
the [ __ ] up man
forever forever so because of covid they
did something new where everybody was at
their homes and they would send somebody
out
in this type of outfit with an emmy so
they had a bunch of extra ones
if you won they would then give you the
emmy and then they'd leave
but some one of the contestants who
actually ended up losing
recorded this is how it looks like in
2020 when you lose an emmy
they just wave and they leave
that would be damn shout out to romney
that's a great show that's a great show
by the way
is it good yeah a really good show oh my
girl one zendaya
yup sunday over 21 right yes she's like
25. 25. yeah she's uh what's that show
good make sure you foreign if you if you
got kids it's terrifying because
you're like was it like a scary like
they're doing it in high school and
doing drugs and [ __ ] and just the
dad's [ __ ] it's crazy
it's so good a lot of dicks and a lot of
dicks and day is so good in it she's so
cool he's doing a lot of ding-a-lings
yeah it's fantastic i should have been
on there i got a little piece
you were on uh insecure yeah i was only
security insecure
he was also in creed yeah come on man
dope yeah
you got a resume got a little credit you
know check his imbd
yeah you know what you got we know
you're out there oh this is yours
brendan
oh the guy from uh the doc on showtime
uh what was the documentary called oh
cry right
outcry do you know do you know about
this wait wait what is going on
what happened so outcry is a documentary
this isn't a spoiler this is
it's a [ __ ] documentary but outcry is
documentary this kid
is on show time is so good this kid's
like the number one recruit in texas
yeah in austin he's a safety a white
safety
and he goes to stay with like this
family because
he lived far away from the school and
this lady who had a daycare was like he
can stay with me so he'd have to drive
all the time
and then uh it comes out like the kid
the the
gets this kid here gets accused of
uh sexual assault unlike molesting kids
loses everything goes on trial goes to
prison goes on trial
turns out there's falsely accused and
there's actually another kid
and you learn look into the dean you
look into the policing
and like the the criminal system there
and it's so corrupt they didn't look
into anybody else
they just [ __ ] this kid so he's
supposed to go play he had a full ride
scholarship to san antonio
uh texas san antonio university that got
revoked everything
so this just came out he just got a full
ride scholarship play at eastern
michigan
bro that makes me want to tear up yeah a
little bit watch the dock
because with kids the first two episodes
you all [ __ ] this dude touch that kid
yeah and then the more they look into
like oh [ __ ] he didn't do it and they
they ruined his life dude ruined his
life so do you get money behind that
like if he because he potentially missed
out on millions though
he had nothing damn it's just like oh
i'm sorry my bad we messed up
but and even the people that [ __ ] him
over
yeah they still have these tough jobs
i'm saying like royally
like purposely [ __ ] it came out that
his lawyer
would had some agenda ties to the other
kid who actually did it
it's so [ __ ] up it'll make you scared
man you watch like
what it's on show time yeah you just
wanna stay in the house
you gotta you gotta watch it it's such a
good day from texas we're going down
there i'm i'm inside the whole time
inside yeah it makes me wanna have fun
now but everything is outdoors in texas
no
oh texas is lit texas
i was just talking i was just that's the
risk you got to take
but if you watch outcry this is a great
story i'll cry
so good i'm gonna watch that but it's
cool he got a full ride to emu
where is it at 12 weeks like 2 a.m
watch it yo i'm watching it eastern
michigan crips
what else you got oh yeah much later
yeah
i watched uh was that called friday
night lights
that was a good movie yeah john claude
van damme jean-claude this is weird
someone said this to me um i'll find his
name in a bit but i'll play it for you
first
he's doing a music video yeah it's
trippy though check this out
[Music]
this is fantastic i respect you know
what i'm going to do
i'm going to do this in dallas i'm going
to post it on saturday
i'm going to do this exact same thing
you have purple pants
we're cool pants figure it out
i'm going to do this
recreate this video i'm not going to
recreate yeah you're not going to it's
not going to rock
side to side like you can miss you're
not going to be at the beach but i don't
know
what was that what was the purpose i
guarantee martin can edit me into it
you can edit all this for me wow that
looks fantastic yeah you write this song
no he did not i have i doubt he did but
he's also just
yeah he's like flying private doing all
these doing all this blow
oh he was in the blow oh yeah you don't
become jean-claude van damme do the
splits every goddamn day
you got it you need a little bit of a
little blow yeah i don't have much he
was my
favorite dude yeah i love bloodsport you
were the steven seagal guy or
jean-claude van damme i was jealous that
was hardcore
your steaming cigar yeah i love leave
the weapon you just
steven seagal no i love sport dude you
can get out you can stay
he's saying just because i got dissolved
hard to kill
leave the weapon you're thinking mel
gibson also get the [ __ ] out
god dawg wow yeah wait stephen seagal is
that thick
mexican who knew kung fu he's more yes
i'm sitting here
he's not he's a white guy but he also
has his
citizenship in russia well put a push
bro john claude
i'm sorry steven is a giant mexican who
fooled everyone thinking he's asian
part but he's not norris chuck norris is
mexican yes
no chuck norris is not mexican yeah his
real name is carlos
really yeah oh he has a russian
citizenship
yeah he's white no no he loves russia
anyone goes russia that is not
apparently anybody that goes to russia
looks mexican seagal was born in lansing
michigan
all right wait really chuck norris is a
stephen cigar baby
yeah no he was thinking the truck wait
chuck norris is not mexican
his name is carlos his real name really
i think he's mexican
wait hold on thomas stop it stop it now
oh never mind native american oh yes i'm
sticking with steven sugar i used to
watch
hey oh really name the biggest japanese
guy you know
there's no japanese guys with guts and
six six i don't i don't i'm not no i'm
not in them streets
i don't know i'm not over there i'm not
over there
[Laughter]
this is a viral video of the fire nato's
who's that
isn't this in like the bay area that's
also on fire
a tornado world's coming to an end yeah
this is hard i like that
not the world coming to the campus hit
it chin how long be refreshed it's not
working
this is in norcal i think it's nor cal
well it's close to us
holy [ __ ]
if you look outside your window you saw
that what would you do
i don't know chill let's see where she
is
call steven seagal no you call chuck
norris because
he's the one no he's got all these facts
about him stephen will come up with that
it says california what is it
california california wild golden state
i don't know exactly where it is but i
remember
they're supposed to be in the bay area
it's horrible man hopefully they take
down the warriors
what would make you totally take down
the words would you guys ever consider
leaving california uh
yeah i just got here
you been here well i mean we've been
here for a minute but i'm saying i like
it though like you like it here
yeah but i'll move though but i mean
yeah but where are we
i would like yeah i mean to get out of
like
the chaotic you know you're in hollywood
i'm in hollywood dude i'm telling you
and you can stay with me during the
elections get the [ __ ] out of there
yeah get out of there what's going on no
matter who wins there's gonna be riots
especially if trump wins they're gonna
be riots all over man bro he's talking
about my home
my home man wait hold on time out now
wait wait wait whoa why are you gonna
give me this information it's gonna be
he's just gonna live in hollywood what
that what i love about chris y'all
close to wait wait live off control
there's a lot of people online that
um bro somewhere we'll talk off air yeah
but
it's it you're out though you're in the
heart of it i'm in the heart of
hollywood
get out i almost just said no shop
right there it's gonna get bad northern
california and also
from nevada california border just so
people know
but yeah that's a fine chin's downtown
telling chin elections get out i already
bought my gun did i tell you
so i actually bought it it's coming in
soon yeah what what type of gun glock 17
you need 19. you need that ar-15 so i
can't carry them
news to me papa has three of them news
to you
i don't think you can have an ar here i
haven't got my dad
legally oh okay you can't have the the
you can't have automatic you can't have
automatic and
you can only have a certain mag yeah but
if i go to texas
they'll switch out the mag i want what
doc holliday had
oh dude not enough not enough i know but
i just want that for me
all right i want to be a gunslinger you
just got your first gun
first gun yeah cause i living in
downtown it's just
you're gonna want a gun now especially
now yeah but uh so my brother told me
you can't have more than 10
10 rounds in a magazine so it's harder
to find the glocks for california yeah
so i wonder if you do this all online or
did you go to a store online but they so
it's online they ship it to an actual
store
once you go to the store you have to
pass the test yeah or study the test
pass it's a business
then also to get 50 pages 50 pages then
also to get ammunition for ar15
is a beast too yeah you go through the
same procedures just get the ammunition
right so they make it tough to get guns
right yeah which is good
also give me my photograph but also if
i don't get to get a gun in there on the
street but on the street
but i don't know a couple homies for a
throw away
california's a big shooting to the side
like arizona left it's easy
yeah yeah everyone goes out and shoots i
mean arizona's like wild wild west but i
tell you what
i mean you break into someone's house in
arizona there's a 99
chance that texas too but in california
too like when they're talking about the
protesters
yeah if they start going like in the
residential areas a lot of people have
guns but
they don't want to deal with that yeah
what else are you
doing cat you have a gun no i don't
have a gun huh your sister have a gun no
why would we have guns
why would we need you know what i got
that i just the world's on fire
type of life do you think i'm living it
is hopefully a safe one
you know what i have that they told me i
can't have a grenade a dream no
a dream chuck i have nunchucks
illegal it's so dumb it's so dumb i know
you can have a gun but you can't have
that you gotta have life i know how to
use them let's see if they're still
illegal
you gotta have a license uh-huh well i
don't have them anymore
no i'm so serious what is weird yeah
what is that about
numchucks yep illegal to possess in
california except in martial arts
classes
yeah that's so dumb some of these rules
are so dumb outright illegal in new york
arizona and
massachusetts wow i got them in texas
from a buddy i mean they're they're just
like a display thing i don't know
you could just make them so easily with
like music so
it's it's fun using them on things yeah
how do you get the timing
uh i don't know i just youtube i watch
youtube videos
i learned the weirdest [ __ ] dude i just
feel like good at it i just know how to
use it what else you got jen
uh do you remember that hoverboard
writing dentist who went viral like he
was doing a procedure while he's
riding a hoverboard no you don't know
this i've been so mad
yeah so everyone was bad they were all
pissed off he's getting 12 years in
prison
so because of that they saw they found
out more stuff there when they looked
into him
okay like hoverboard yeah and so that
didn't [ __ ] him but
he was doing bad problems administering
more drugs than necessary to
in order to build patients higher um he
had taken 2.5 million from
medicaid unnecessarily and then this is
the the worst part
so he's performing anesthesia and that's
that's something that's super critical
like if you don't know what you're doing
kills criticism yeah you kill someone
yeah that's why anesthesiologists make
the most money
they make tons of money so he did it
without training or consent
thousands of times they said and he
stole money oh he's [ __ ]
yeah yeah so after even after 12 years
when he's in prison
he has 10 years probation where he can't
do a dentistry
he's super yeah he better not he
probably won't go back no it all started
from the hoverboard yep
[ __ ] that's what you get you're
hoverboarding that's what i'm saying
when you speak
look american gangster what happened to
what happened to uh
frank lucas he you see you snitched no
uh
started dressing flashlights he started
dressing oh cause his girl his girl
suggested girl suggested that
that's what that's what happened around
he's being too flashy
i love how we call your brother jay
bayless now that's his name
i'm so sorry for you yeah you should no
it's fun straight i'm like jaden that's
exhausting
oh my god let's not bring that up cause
we we literally was arguing this morning
anyways yeah don't be too loud about
your [ __ ] bro don't be too loud dog
one more check out this uh crocodile
of course it's in australia
so there's a boat he's swimming right
next to the boat
look at look how fast
so yeah that was a video and i looked at
the the speed of them or whatever
i guess they are they could go 37 miles
per hour for me jesus christ
[ __ ] sheesh
i watch uh this morning with my son
because he's into insects right now
and we found a black widow and he's like
are those dangerous like
super dangerous super so i looked up
coyote our boy coyote peterson who was
on the episode of fighting kid
he gets bit by i brought that dude on we
had him on here yeah
kind of before he's big time now he's
like big time like dude he's crazy
dude he got stung by a uh uh murder
hornet
uh-huh i think that uh i forget what
they're called if you bring it up chin i
can't even show but
he got bit by it's one of the most
powerful ones everyone's scared of him
it's brave wilderness yeah and which one
the bullet ant he starts freaking out
it's hilarious
if you just click on it bullets i mean
uh the cicada killer cicada killer
look at the size of this [ __ ] hornet
look at that thing
no it's that top one four million views
he puts it on and it's like in the can
hard pass it's in the container it's
like shaking the container by the cicada
killer oh my goodness that stinger is
wrong here we go
wait hold the hell up you know what i
like though coyotes real because it
stings him he's like oh [ __ ] and he's
like not that bad
he's like it's really not that bad look
at the sides that thing though
isn't going in oh there it goes
ah oh i got away
oh get away but i like that he's real
about it because he's
not that bad and then the reason i
brought it up is because we
found a black widow on my basketball
court a big-ass black widow my son's
like oh my god
so i sprayed it with water and he's like
those dangerous i'm like yeah so i
brought up to
the coyote's page because there's a
video of him with a black widow i
thought it was him getting bit by a
black widow
but he put he finds a black widow in his
house he just lets it walk up
around his arm he's like they're not
that dangerous yeah
oh really no he's like they don't want
to hurt people i've seen quite a few
people do that with the black widow
where they let it walk
that's what he does i'm i'm not gonna
let
him i wouldn't do it oh i know yeah but
i don't even when you see a black widow
that's thing about nature like you know
these things are [ __ ] dangerous
that that can potentially
this is the exact one i found in my
house
they're really cool looking though i
know
but he lets her just crawl all over like
she's pretty cool does it does it like
it's you a little bit like creep you up
like cause my feeling my natural
reaction would be like that like man
that's when they bite you but that's
what they say you should grab a stick
and just take it
most people are gonna freak the [ __ ] out
but they say you should grab a stick and
just put it on a branch
gosh because they don't wanna bite you
they don't wanna oh they don't
yeah they buy you when you like put your
foot in the shoe and they're hiding in
there yeah something like when you
ambush it
so they're yeah they're a defense yeah
yeah yeah okay
even you know with all i think that's
how rattlesnakes are too i'm not gonna
trust me
you see you see him on your trail dude
nature let you know not to [ __ ] with
this stuff yeah
like black widow obviously dangerous
looking that wasp one of the wasps
is like a metallic purple like it's
nature being like dude
leave these things the [ __ ] you see
around like some rattlesnakes i'll see
i'll post a picture of it or a video of
it
they're like uh like a metallic blue
brown like
you know not they look so evil like you
should not [ __ ] with them in yeah
well for the most part they leave you
alone like even when i'm saying even
when i ride by them if
one of they'll just stare at you they
don't do it they don't want to [ __ ] with
you
they're so scary looking though you're
like holy [ __ ] dude
what are you ever eating rattlesnake no
you have a
rattlesnake no they have a place back
home in arizona where they louisiana
where i'm from they eat everything
yeah that's true overall rattlesnake
alligator crap
again like these all these like
alligators rattlesnakes great whites
[ __ ] black widows the cicada wasp
the bullet ant the [ __ ] um
all these all these all these dangerous
animals like nature's letting you know
don't [ __ ] with them
they have all these crazy colors for a
reason ralph sings are so [ __ ] cool
looking we see him in person though like
oh
[ __ ] you know right away what color is
it because on the on the trails like
different there's different ones
but on the trail you'll know like
because i do it so many times like you
all see like a big like
long way you can hear it you'll see it
yeah you can
hear them if you're close and they're in
the bush or if you're like
going down the road you'll see like i
just know the trails like the back of my
hand now that i've been doing it every
[ __ ] day
so i'll see like it looks like a like a
thick branch but it's moving
you know you won't confuse it for a
branch but also they won't they don't
come out in the winter time
come on oh no they can't even move
they hibernate during hibernate yeah
they can't even move like quick or
anything
but you see how light that one is none
of them look like that yeah how big how
big
so you you're probably thinking the
western diamondback that's what i see i
don't see that
and dude they're you'll know you'll
[ __ ] know
they're so dope looking yeah and i'll
know like if i go at like nine
right if like i usually i'm on my bike
for like two and a half hours
if by if i go at nine by the time it's
11 it's hot out they come out i know
exactly where they're at
and what do they do they just be
chilling you just see them i love seeing
them
i'm disappointed when i don't see them
what i don't get is i'll see like a girl
and i'm like yo rattlesnake up there
they don't give a [ __ ]
really don't give a [ __ ] that's
something their dog off the leisure like
literally
right once you get around the bend
there's a huge rattler you might go
thanks and they
they don't put their dog on the leash
i'm like all right you know who [ __ ] up
rattlesnakes
road runners yes roadrunners [ __ ] now
roadrunners we saw them
i first i've never seen when we're in
phoenix yeah oh yeah dude road runners
don't look like the cartoon they don't
they're small yeah they're like real
smug but they're quick
you just see them running yeah they're
kind of cool do coyotes catch them in
real life
i don't know would i would assume
that road runners are actually [ __ ]
they look like [ __ ]
they do not yeah that's when i saw a
little thing i'm like they're all over
females
and they'll go after a rattlesnake in
harvard oh we're in phoenix in november
we're back in there
[Laughter]
what does the cartoon one look like
again bruh bring up uh
huh yeah i forget what he looks like
though
but he's like red and blue isn't he yep
there it is right there oh no he's just
blue and look how hard it looks
see how long he looks exactly he's way
bigger than wiley coyote no no they're
taller
look at that [ __ ] yeah exactly that's so
dope chin go
to if he's um it's probably malik's
probably closer
last time we're in phoenix that's when
we did the thick boy dance oh yeah
oh yeah yeah i was i was thinking i was
thinking of uh
how you how you made me go viral look at
that look at that we had a gift i was
like girl i was texting people with a
gift
right there right there right there
right there right uh right there so this
is a recreation of a video
yeah you should do it now
[Music]
look at b with the moves i know brittany
look at the moves though this is one
take by the way this is watching
the video and then copy it let's get it
come on
when he started boxing i didn't know how
to react i didn't i was like okay just
he took off the shirt i was like okay he
getting
he feeling it he feeling it let's go
so funny look at what he did he killed
me with lawrence with that arm there
look
[Music]
a massive human being all right man yeah
yeah i know
you are them look they say token malik
what the hell does that mean what does
that mean
come on bro i hated how they said every
day it was about yo
you and i was like where's the women
they're like
it's all dudes i get all dudes
i was like where's the women well you
can see this crew in
dallas next week thursday friday
saturday addison improv
you can see us in phoenix early november
you can see
nashville you have tampa in october i'll
be in tampa second week of october right
um
the 15th through the 18th side splitters
tampa i'll be in vegas this weekend if
it means
where you at in vegas lake las vegas uh
the 20's oh yeah yeah yeah you're
supposed to do the show
oh you guys are married no we're not
married it's a kiss anniversary the
first time they kissed
no it's not it's not the kisses we do
have a piece of breakfast that is when
he told me that [ __ ]
i was like you know what we were doing a
show at the comedy store i said hey dawg
i got a jet
uh i got mine and my girl's kissiversary
i was like wait bruh what he stuck his
hand down and pulled it back
what the [ __ ]
vegas this weekend yes beggars did you
shows in tampa in october
october 5th all of us will be together
next weekend in dallas yes sir we'll be
in nashville together
we'll also be in arizona phoenix okay
wait
t-fatkay.com for tickets guys love you
thank you
see you out there on the road yeah we're
out ufc 253 is this weekend
you can bet one dollar and win 100 if
you pick style ben or costa
and your pick wins with draftkings
sportsbook america's top rated
sportsbook app
if you haven't tried draftking
sportsbook head to the app store right
now because you don't want to miss this
again
draftkings sportsbook is giving all new
users the chance to turn
one dollar into 100 all you got to do is
pick the
headliner who wins style bender or paulo
costa
and one dollar you could win 100 if
you're new to draftking sportsbook head
to the app right now
and check out their latest offers
draftkings is safe reliable secure
and they make it easy for you to deposit
withdraw your money whenever
you want download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app
now use the promo code fighter when you
sign up to get this can't miss offer
pick either headline fighter during ufc
253 bet one dollar
and you can win 100 dollars if you pick
correctly
that's one dollar to win 100 dollars
using the promo code
fighter during sign up for limit time
only at draftkings sportsbook
must be 21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
eligibility restrictions supply c
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call wendy 800 gambler or in
indiana 109 with it